Right,
too.
Boom.
And we're alive.
My man.
What's up baby?
First of all,
how the fuck do you punched so hard,
hard punches,
man.
I've been watching boxing since I was a little kid.
You've got some freakish power,
man.
Weird.
You got weird power the most definitely.
Oh,
we always say I'm a freak of nature.
I definitely got some type of freakish power.
Um,
I always tell the story that my grandmother said I was anointed by God.
She was always like,
if I got suspended for school and stuff,
she was always like,
God is trying to use you.
You're the one you are chosen.
You know?
She was very big and you know,
she was big in the,
in the spirit,
spirituality and Christianity,
you know,
so she's always be a teacher.
You know,
she wasn't really a discipline,
disciplinary type of woman.
She was a teacher.
She wanted to teach or tell you certain things.
She used to always say how I was annoying.
She won't even let my parents woke me.
Well,
not in front of her.
That's how serious you were.
She like,
she like,
don't you been out with him?
He's going to be the one that bring you up.
He didn't want to be the one that bring you guys up.
Don't whoop him.
You know?
Um,
somebody tells you something like that at a young age,
you might believe it.
Well,
I didn't even realize that really,
you know,
just being so young,
just being,
you know,
we,
we did as children.
Do,
you know,
I didn't really think too much about it because I didn't understand what she was
saying.
You know,
I ain't started understanding until you start putting away child his ways and
you become a grown man and you start venturing out in life and experience in
life on your own and started seeing certain things.
And then even,
even when I got out on my own,
you know,
I really,
there's a lot of things,
I didn't start on understanding until I was 30,
you know what I'm saying?
Just to,
you know,
cause certain things,
different things,
what happened in my life,
you know,
and that you,
sometimes you just give you the,
you,
you deal with it and you handle it the best way you can handle.
But it's certain things that starts to happen.
He was like,
my grandma said something about this or,
you know,
it's just,
and,
um,
that's how my life been.
But it's amazing how I can come in at two oh nine and father God is that coming
in at two 16 and,
and able to drop him like I did.
Like,
it's crazy,
but we all are always been stronger than mine than what I've looked.
It's interesting that the cruiserweight division doesn't get any love.
I mean,
the last time it got lovers with Evander Holyfield was fine.
Yeah.
That was really the last time people cared about the cruiserweight division.
Now it's a forgotten division.
Kinda almost.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
You know,
um,
you know,
my brother just starting in the,
in the,
in the cruiserweight division,
hopefully he can bring some excitement to it because you,
you're so right.
You know,
it's almost like they don't even talk about it.
It doesn't make any sense because the light heavyweight division gets a lot of
love,
love watching light.
Heavyweight fights always gets lots of attention.
But the cruiserweight division is always like people looking at like,
why are you here?
Yeah.
But on some weight go up.
Yup.
It's true.
It's true because the heavier ways always overshadow those guys.
Did you really wait two oh nine the night of the fight?
I weighed two on the night of the fight.
I was out when they came in the way media,
it would just want to get an official way in and see,
see where you are.
So I'm all confident and like I like,
I know I didn't went up from two 12 and um,
I get on the scale and it says two are now like,
I like what you mean to tell me I lost three more pounds.
You know,
I'm like,
how did I,
how did I do that?
My manager,
you know,
he thinks it's come from stress and a lot of little different things or whatever
the last couple of days.
Right before the fight that allow your body just,
just overall,
a lot of stuff was,
you know,
a lot of stuff going on.
He thinks it's because of that,
you know,
cause your body,
you're the balance of your,
your body and all that and stuff like that.
But I really don't know.
I really don't really care about weight because majority of my fighter,
the majority of the fighters that have fought me,
they've all waved me like almost all my career,
you know?
So I always say I'd rather be the park then looked apart because I've been in
many situations where I've seen guys looking the part,
but then when it's,
when it get to the nitty gritty,
then not depart.
Well,
you look the part too.
You don't get it twisted
giant Tommy Hearns yeah.
You know,
when Tommy was in his prime,
it's just,
uh,
it's what,
what makes sense though is that you keep that power in the 12th round.
Where's those bigger,
heavier guys?
Maybe because the blood's got to push through all that extra muscle and all that
extra body tissue.
Maybe they can't keep that power of the way you can because in the 12th round,
first of all,
I don't know how the fuck he got up.
I do not understand.
I remember watching it on TV.
I'm like,
wow,
he knocked him out in the 12th round.
That is crazy.
Right.
It's crazy.
And then of course you played that thing on your Instagram,
which basically shows that you did knock them out.
Right.
Oh,
definitely knocked him out.
He definitely didn't get up in time.
He definitely didn't,
you know,
but it was his job to just get up
10.
It's not his job to know exactly when,
10 seconds.
Yes.
Correct.
No,
jet Reese definitely had delays on that account.
I haven't seen the fight like six times.
And then definitely when he got to eight,
you know,
eight was a very long delay.
Eight then he said no,
you know,
um,
like I said,
99 out of 10 judges would have waved at all,
you know,
easily.
Especially when you've seen the guy our rolling in the back of his head and he
and him hitting the canvas and his,
his,
his whole head meat penetrate penetrated.
Like it started getting tight.
The muscles in the head getting tight in the back.
And
you know what,
it's,
it's so much with that.
I know how he got,
I didn't understand how he got up either.
And God is a good God.
Well,
he believed it.
That's what he believed.
He believed it.
He got up man and he got up and he boxed.
Well he recovered
you.
You mean you came after him and you hit him with some more big shots and he kept
moving,
but then he started getting his legs back under them and then he started Landen
does also other things as well too.
You know,
he's still a gypsy though.
Yeah.
You know,
you know,
they believe in a lot of things,
right.
So you never know,
you know,
fucking phenomenal fight though.
Epic.
It was absolutely amazing to watch.
Most definitely.
I watched it by myself with family was gone.
They went out for the day.
So I was like,
this is great.
Just me.
Did you watch it on mute now?
See what I'm saying?
The commentators,
man,
they was horrible.
It was horrible.
I felt it was very biased.
It was a lot of things.
They was pulling out what period we're doing,
but a lot,
a lot of things what I was doing,
it just,
even when I knocked down in the knife round,
they had all this to say,
but when I'm not done,
the knife went on.
It was so quiet and it wasn't even a devastating knockout.
I was getting hit behind the head,
but they want to call out me hitting him behind the ear.
But how many times I got hit behind the head never was revealed.
It was like even just this,
just the whole,
you know,
bill up to it,
he sold his story,
he sold his go over to America and you know,
any combat sport it did with emotional emotions,
you know,
people got emotionally tied to it.
People,
a lot of people could relate to his story,
you know,
certain things.
I could relate to it.
And then,
you know,
when,
when you,
you,
when you capture,
you know,
the world and you capture people that,
that,
um,
they get emotional involved,
they want you to win.
Right.
You know,
just because of the stuff I've worn them and when and stuff like that.
And,
um,
the commentators,
you know,
especially Paul especially,
uh,
got very emotional with it.
A lot of the other cats as well too,
just going back,
listening to them,
I didn't saw the fight six times,
you know?
Um,
I definitely had it.
You can see a very,
a better look on the fight,
muting the TV,
you know,
well,
listen
to the commentary,
but,
you know,
I do commentary myself or UFC.
So a lot of times,
even if I'm listening and I'm not really listen that much,
I'm just watching you watching what's happening.
It's like I'm having a conversation in a room with a bunch of people,
right?
I was watching what was happening but it was interesting to me was a you made
adjustments,
you know and one thing that you made it big adjustment is um,
when you landed in the 12th round,
you shorten everything up.
You shorten that right hand up.
It wasn't a winging punch at all.
It came straight down the pipe and then that left hand behind him in the fucking
timing cause he was already going down.
You already hit,
I'm clean.
He's going down.
Then that fucking left hook man.
Whew.
That was what was really crazy that he got up from,
cause we'll snapped him around like the extra cyst.
It was when he went flying and then flat line and laid back.
I was like it's over.
I can't believe he knocked him out in the 12 fucking round cause all fight.
I was saying all this guy needs is one punch.
Like you got that scary creepy power and boom,
what you could say that all day long.
But if it never lands it doesn't mean anything.
Right.
And it landed and the way it lands,
it was like Holy Shit.
I told her,
I said,
you're going to have to be perfect for 12 wells.
I only have to be perfect for a couple of seconds.
That's one thing that I did hear the commentators say.
They said that he's proven that he doesn't have to be perfect cause he got hit,
but it was like he,
but he didn't get hit clean.
He got hit one time,
like pretty solid behind the year,
but the big one was in the 12th.
I'm so impressed with both things.
With you being able to land like that with him,
been able to get up.
That was probably one of the best heavyweight fights by fucking ever seen
crush on me that night.
You don't?
Sure.
I'm,
the heavyweight division has,
has been dead for,
for long time.
And then we started with last year or something to just started religious
progressing and people started talking about it.
Um,
especially been dead in America.
I remember a time when no one knew who was,
who was the heavyweight champion of the World War,
you know,
it was a European guys and stuff like that.
So I always made it my business,
like I want to bring it back,
I want to do it like I lead it and a lot of the other former champions did it
where people knew where understand the sport of boxing then who was the champion
and stuff like that.
I always felt I had that,
that duty to fulfill even when I was in the Olympics because a lot of people
don't even know I was in the Olympics,
you know?
Um,
I was the only American tomato because in 2008 Olympics as well.
And just from that point it has felt like I had to be the one to bring it back
and to come to la.
They bring all the stars and like I got everyone here.
And you met with the Olympics,
quit pretty soon.
Pretty young in your boxing career from the time you started training?
Correct.
Like what,
how long was it in until you were fighting the Olympics?
I made the Olympic team in a year and a half.
I started boxing.
I started boxing at 21 you know how fucking crazy that is.
So a year and a half a boxing,
he make the Olympic team and you won a bronze medal.
That's,
that's insane.
You know,
they didn't even have my name written on the list of the one that's going to be
on the team.
You know,
they always say,
I was,
uh,
I just came out of nowhere.
Wouter came out of nowhere,
you know,
I remember being in the,
I'm in a tournament and he had this elder man,
you know,
he's seen these kids like year after year after year.
And um,
he,
I remember him saying,
I said,
who are you?
I'm Deontay wilder.
And he looked at as the guy next to him,
you know,
where are you from?
I said,
I'm from Alabama,
Alabama.
He laughed at me
because they never seen or from Alabama,
you know,
we was based off with football and basketball and stuff like that.
I didn't even,
I was surprised it was a gym in Alabama when I did start,
you know,
I was like,
wow.
Like I can't believe,
like I'm in a boxing gym.
I never thought one would be here.
We didn't do that,
you know,
just Steve about it.
But I started because of my daughter that was born with spinal Bifida.
So you know,
I couldn't play football and basketball a little more because you had to go to
school for that.
I needed money right now,
you know,
so I was looking at a,
a way of making money like right now and you know,
I had a friend in college,
we was always talking about what we want to try to do and what are the things we
were trying to do to get to that point because you know,
talk is cheap.
We can always say,
well we want,
but if you're not applying any type of action towards what you w with your
words,
you just,
it just,
it's just talk,
you know,
he said he thought I said [inaudible] he thought I should start boxing.
Um,
I thought it was a great idea as well too.
He thought he thought I should start,
but only for the simple fact that I handled myself well streetwise.
You know,
nobody ever seen me just lose or get beat up streetwise.
I was this quiet guy.
I tell people I never look for trouble,
but trouble always found me for some reason.
And,
um,
and when I did release the anger,
when I release,
like it was,
it was even back then was dramatic,
you know what I'm saying?
And I'm a kid.
You not even back then I believe in,
you know,
and,
um,
I could never come down though at that point.
I was like the hulk,
I couldn't come down.
It took me a lot to come down.
Even if I will see blood,
I still wouldn't calm down.
And he used to be scary for me because I,
you know,
even back then I had power,
but I was just,
I had a lot of aggression.
I had a lot of anger for some reason.
I never know why,
you know,
and,
um,
and we thought it was a great idea.
Like,
you know what?
I'm gonna do it,
you know,
I can't lose,
what can I lose,
you know?
And,
um,
just went to the [inaudible] with the guy,
went to the gym.
You know,
I've been in Tuscaloosa,
Alabama and I walked in there.
I kid you not,
I felt like I heard the bells.
I mean,
the heart,
the sounds to heavily said,
Ooh,
I swear I kicked,
when I walked up in there,
it was just to the speed bag and the heavy band being hitting the conversations
and then the guys sparring and my eyes everywhere like this.
I never been in some,
a place like this before ever.
You know what?
I'm just,
it's just,
it's like new to me and how like I felt like this was it.
This is my last opportunity to be someone,
uh,
to be a,
a professional athlete and be able to make money for my daughter.
I didn't know I came in as a journey.
Me Julius man,
that's what I wanted to be.
I didn't want to,
you know,
I didn't know nothing about amateur.
And I knew about Ali and the Wa,
you know what?
He did his journey,
his amateur.
But I knew that I didn't even knew the term or of an amateur.
Like what,
what is it?
You know what I'm saying?
So walking into the gym,
my whole mentality was to make money from my daughter.
I didn't like,
Yo,
let me learn just the fundamentals.
It's just stick me out of there.
But then we also,
we had this conversation in the gym about the Olympic trials and the Olympics.
So I remember it briefly,
like we started talking about me and my trainer now.
We started talking about it and then it just became a whole big Jim discussion.
Everybody stopped doing what they was doing just to get in on this conversation.
We didn't know how to get there.
Well we knew that if we kept winning that we or will we eventually get to that
point.
So I just kept knocking guys out.
It's just kept winning and kept winning.
And then that's how I got on the Olympics team.
And then I told my daughter when w you know,
I met,
made the Olympic team,
I metal and did all that.
And then I turned pro shortly after and I don't remember telling my daughter
when she was one years old,
I said,
daddy going to be a world champion and he's going to be able to support you
beyond your belief.
You know,
for me it meant a lot for me to say that to her because I come from a playful
offer for your purposes.
You know,
you ever had someone promised you something and you wait for years and gears,
it don't happen.
You know,
you still holding on to that promise that they told you,
especially being a child,
you know,
you still are like are,
until it just don't happen no more.
Or you see that certain thing that was positive being given is no more there is
it,
it's gone,
you know,
and um,
that really hurting me,
you know,
at times just coming up.
That's why I'm a man of my word now,
you know,
if I sell someone something,
you can take it to the bank,
you know,
Eh,
it's going to happen.
You know,
it's just,
you know,
God is on time guys,
so they don't come.
We want it,
but it's always on time when he's involved.
And when I'm involved,
when I say something,
I try to make it,
it's gone.
You know,
I'm a man of my word.
No matter what I say.
See Walking the gym,
you have this feeling,
you,
you know that this is where you're meant to be.
And do you just how far ways it's Jen from your house
at that time?
This gym,
I'm still in touch with the more important,
that's about 30,
probably about 45 minutes from where I live too far.
You can go,
you can get there.
How often are you going there?
Every day.
Change Life.
Yeah.
You know what?
I was still working for Budweiser.
I was driving the truck for Budweiser.
So,
um,
at times,
you know,
anybody work at Budweiser know that you,
you got a specific time to come in,
but you don't have a time where you get off.
You know,
sometimes you can work from five hours depending on if you have a bar,
Baruch,
which is the easiest.
And then,
um,
you can have a 17 hour day,
which I didn't have before where you had to go to way deep in the south,
way deep in other cities or whatever.
I used to have a stop that took me two hours to get that before I even,
you know,
two hours to get there before I even can work my first stop.
And you're talking about having 17 stops on your,
on your,
on your list to do you want me on your to do list and your first stop is two
hours,
you know what I mean?
That's,
that was a hell of a ride just to be able to,
it's depressed.
It makes you depressed just because you got to wait two hours just to get
started.
You Ready?
You want to go home as soon as possible.
I remember times where I used to drive the big truck to the,
to the,
to the gym.
So you would have a big Budweiser truck advertising but like outside of the
cheer and you'll see me out there.
It used to be times where I used to sleep in my car right there at the gym.
You know,
I really wanted to get it.
I told my that will be a world champion and I was devoted to the sport,
which I still am still there to this day.
Uh,
but it was a lot of sacrifices.
I had to sacrifice for my daughter to,
to religious be here,
to be able to support her with spinal Bifida because I knew I knew nothing about
the disorder.
I'm 19 years old,
you know,
I'm just trying to a father,
a loving father,
just trying to support his daughter.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
That's a different kind of motivation,
man.
Then being in Alabama,
we had to scrape up money to go to other states because we didn't really have
too many heavy weights here,
you know,
so we had to go find sparring elsewhere.
My trainer tells the story to this day,
you know how we had to scrape up because you get a lot of people want to come
apart and be a part now,
whatever.
He always said,
why?
What's your,
how?
What?
We were scraping up to change and,
and you know,
we,
you know,
we had to scrape up money for gas and something to eat and stuff,
which is all true,
you know,
all had to scrape it up.
Did anybody ever teach you to punch before you started boxing?
Did you ever have an uncle that helped pads for you or anything?
Nah,
now we're not nothing and I didn't know nothing about boxing.
Right.
You,
you definitely knew how to punch people.
Of course.
For sure.
Did you learn just from watching TV?
Like you know,
just like street wise,
you know what I mean?
I mean,
the best thing,
the best thing in life is,
is,
is experience it for yourself.
Life teaches you everything.
You know,
sometimes you can get knowledge from books,
but it's nothing like real life,
real reality.
So you went the same trainers that you were when you first started.
I,
one of the few,
you still with the same one.
That's amazing too.
Yeah.
So how long did it take before it started feeling right to you in terms of like
throwing combinations and move in and it took awhile.
It took awhile because I had to,
I had to wait in the Olympics,
I had to play catch up.
I'm always,
I always was playing catch up because these guys,
they'd been bikes and ever since they was young little boys and stuff.
And you know,
that's how I learned a really about boxing and,
and how it would take your life away from you.
You know,
I'm looking at,
I'm looking at these young guys,
they coming up and several of them,
several of them cannot go to school because I boxing,
you know,
some of them that they were telling me how they've missed birthdays,
they've missed holidays,
they've missed classes from school just to fulfill the dreams,
you know,
it could take,
it'll take everything away from you.
And I've seen some have graduated high school,
you know,
and that's a great accomplishment when you inbox and to graduate high school,
because there's so much,
there's so many tournaments in so many different things.
Cause boxing a year round sport,
you know what I mean?
So it's so many different things that would go on to these kids.
You know,
these guys would try to,
you know,
make this team made that team go to this trip,
go over that trip just to get their spirits and I'm listening to them tell they
story and here I am,
you know,
just coming from Tuscaloosa,
Alabama,
just picking it up,
playing catch up.
I'm listening to everyone's story and what a conference,
how they do this and I'm studying the Amo certain things.
Like it was amazing to be able to just go to the Olympics and just do what I did
a complete with these guys.
I was the least least experienced guy in the whole tournament.
Of course the Olympics
snobby a year and a half.
And you probably the least experienced guy to ever medal ever.
Yeah,
probably so else even come close to that.
I bet if you went over the Olympic records of guys who have boxed and metaled,
I bet you're number one with a bullet prior to so close,
a year and a half in.
It was.
It was amazing spiritual just to beat her,
you know what I mean?
If it wasn't for boxing,
I probably would have never been able to,
to travel outside the country.
You know,
boxing,
show me everything.
You know
what's amazing is one of the things that you'd said that the heavyweight
division,
which has always been the glamor division,
right?
When Tyson was the champ and Holyfield was a champ and all these different
fighters to the Holyfield Riddick Bowe era.
I mean these were gigantic fights.
Everybody in the world was watching.
It was a big deal,
but then when Klitschko one,
I remember I was on a plane with a buddy of mine is a comedian and I said,
you know who that is?
And he goes,
no,
I go,
that's the heavyweight champion of the world.
He goes,
get the fuck out of here.
He said,
well,
he goes,
it's a white guy.
I go,
isn't that crazy
like Russia?
And nobody knows who it is because it was a weird thing.
It's like everybody been that Tommy Morrison days,
people,
there's always the great white hope to,
it's always wanted a white guy to be the heavyweight champion.
Cherry Kone,
Larry Holmes,
Larry Holmes beat the fuck out of Jericho.
And then her,
I was in high school when that happened.
Everybody was hoping that a white guy was going to win.
And then when a white guy,
finally one,
nobody gave a shit cause he was kind of,
he's got very effective style,
but it's,
you know,
it's not the most fan friendly.
He wouldn't jab and grab,
you know,
grab ahold une,
he could knock you out if he hits you clean.
And he knocked a lot of guys out and he was a big fucking guy.
Right.
And no one cared.
It was weird.
It was weird because he was a guy living in Germany and he,
you know,
it's huge in Germany and speaking Russian and English and everything else.
And he's a really smart guy.
Nobody cared.
It was weird.
It was fucking weird.
I know.
I remember because boxing was still huge.
People were still paying attention to Floyd Mayweather and Canelo Alvarez.
And Manny Pacquiao meters,
all the lighter weight classes,
they're still getting all this love.
Bernard Hopkins people were watching all these fights.
Nobody gave a shit about the heavyweight division.
It was strange.
They said,
you know,
once you all have an elite America heavyweight,
you know it dies down on it.
They said what goes to heavyweight division?
So does boxing and it's kind of true in some sense,
but,
but if it,
if it didn't happen that way,
it was the heavyweight division died down.
A lot of these guys that got a lot of one wouldn't have gotten no shine halfway
through.
It would've been within the old forest probably.
Sure.
Well maybe it would've just made the whole sport bigger because you know,
this,
this is a good time now for boxing,
there's a lot of really high level champions is a fun time to be a boxing fan to
watch.
But to look at your record like when you went,
went into the wilder fight or what you see is me wanting to,
the Tyson fury fight.
You wouldn't even 39 and [inaudible] 39 and
40 now with 39 knockouts.
That's a movie record like you put,
that's like a guy fighting someone in creed,
right?
If you looked at that,
that's what it would be like.
What is 40 like this is the guy you're fighting.
He's 40 no 39 knockouts.
What?
Like that would be a movie scene.
Like you would be a bad guy in a movie just designed to fuck people up.
But the fact that no one,
you know was was looking at this as this is a,
this was a gigantic cultural moment.
This wasn't just a big heavyweight fight between two the tallest guys and odd,
big tall but move good.
Both.
You guys move real good.
Me and Tyson for two for six foot,
what is he?
Nine six nine two 56 and he's bobbing and moving a lot and he's got that weird
Herky jerky style.
He's a trip man.
It's very unusual to have the two of you guys together.
To me,
in my eyes,
this was like a reemergence of the heavyweight division in pop culture.
It's like everybody was finally paying attention to the heavyweight division in
boxing.
Like finally this was it.
And I was like,
dude,
this is a big fight.
This isn't just a big fight.
But June two guys who are undefeated,
who are at the top of their game,
who will,
you know,
Tyson didn't lose his title.
He had it.
And you know,
they took it away from him,
but he was still undefeated.
So that was a giant cultural moment.
And when the fight went down and turned out to be one of the best heavyweight
title fights ever,
I mean fuck
is amazing.
Even just to listen to you,
you know,
describing and stuff.
I still feel those,
those,
the assignment,
I'm sure.
Why?
Like it was amazing.
It was amazing.
You know,
I'm just ready for the rematch and like if people was incited it and enjoy it,
doubt,
just imagine the rematch.
You know,
this is going to be amazing.
It's going to be incredible.
And it puts Anthony Joshua and a terrible situation,
but he looks off,
are they big?
And now he looks terrible.
He's going to fight some other guy.
No one gives a fuck.
And it's like your titles,
whatever title you got,
their bullshit mean anything.
Everybody knows.
This is where the real title is.
I mean this is just a,
it's a wrap now.
Yes,
it's,
they,
they definitely begging now he's trying to reach out.
All of a sudden now his management has been trying to reach out to minds as
well,
you know?
Um,
but he could have had this opportunity.
He had me near opportunity.
He could've fall Louise or teas.
Yeah.
We could've followed me.
He had a chance to fall in fury as well,
like clean and safe over on that side of it,
playing it safe.
But no,
but you know,
people want to know who's the best now.
You know what I'm saying?
Especially after seeing the theory,
this theory fight,
you know,
people want to see what was the best and,
and I'm trying to,
I've been trying to show people,
you know,
who's the best,
I always say all the best.
I'm going to forever say I'm the best until I get to feed it,
you know?
And,
um,
right now I'm in a candidate for,
you know,
fight of the year and also,
um,
fight,
uh,
um,
fights are the years I didn't have the cane,
I came back with Louisa,
a tease that was an epic one and then it came back with theory,
another app we fight and then we're going to hit the two again.
That's the thing about you that makes it interesting is that you're not just a
guy who knocks guys out,
but you're a guy who can take it.
You're not,
you can take it and you're a guy who figures out a way to win.
Cause there's a lot of guys that when it's going bad,
they don't come back going good.
They went forever.
But when it's going bad,
it's hard for them to come back.
But you figure your way through bad situations and you make adjustments
even,
even when something is going wrong with my body.
Like I had seven operations on my arm,
you know,
it'd been the meditations like surgery breaking,
just breaking my arm turned my boss up,
um,
break breaking my hand.
You know,
many times in my,
in my fights,
I broken my hands is still fought,
you know,
tore my boss.
He'll come in with third degree burns,
you know,
all that stuff.
Like I'm a,
I'm a true warrior,
you know,
I always think I'm like if I do something,
like if I break my hand or when I tore my bicep in the rain,
my whole mentality is train change it to what?
That motherfucker had a fall off.
That's why I'm glad I got to keep fighting.
I got to keep going.
I'm a warrior,
you know,
and you can never tell you no because I still throw it with bad intention.
You know,
I'm still,
you know,
Lennon and hitting it.
Just like with the,
uh,
Chris Areola fight.
When I broke my hand and took,
tore my bicep,
my camp,
my team knew I broke my hand,
but I didn't mention,
I told my boss he'll cause I'm like,
well,
I tell them I don't want no one to panic.
I'm not worrying about it.
I'm going to keep throwing it.
I got to keep me in.
Chris was so surprised that I did all these things and we're still able to throw
it.
It's just a mentality when it comes to comeback,
like my mentality,
just overall,
it just,
I feel I'm the best and if you're going to come and beat me,
you got to come and beat me.
He's just not going to be easy.
That's why most of the guys,
when they fight me,
they bring their a game every last one of them,
you know,
because they know it's going to be tough and they also know I have the power to
get them out of there.
You know?
And a lot of guys,
you know,
th they're afraid of that because I mean over and over again,
like I said,
my power last from the first through the 12th round,
you can never be in like too comfortable with me because of that,
you know?
And,
and
that's big for me to have.
You know,
I've always sat back and like saying,
you know,
I've said the same question myself.
Like damn well you,
you got all this power like,
and you know,
me being the person with it,
I felt many times where I felt dangerous.
I felt like,
I felt like at times it can be too much power because I get scared of myself at
times because I know I've got the potential to potential to hurt someone
seriously.
You know,
just dealing with it.
Just looking back and seeing some of the guys I've knocked out and seeing the
reactions and you know,
the unbroke guy's arms out and broke the ice.
Soccer's Adam,
you know,
put them in seizures,
almost killed speaker in New York.
You know,
he laid there for for a while,
you know,
I didn't even see him breathing,
and so forth for so long.
You know,
it,
it's been amazing to have so much power,
but still trying to understand it as well too,
you know?
And that fire with fear I couldn't,
like,
it was crazy.
I couldn't,
I couldn't stream out right arm off.
They say.
It felt like something was stopping me from really,
really just throwing it straight.
And to the end for some reason like it was,
it was,
it was it because you were trying to knock them out.
So I definitely was trying to knock,
I was very anxious of knocking him out,
but it was something that was holding like I couldn't straighten it out.
I kept going back to my corner.
Like why?
Why you can't throw the right hand is right that this dude would bend down like
right here in slow motion.
It seemed like to me,
I've seen this look many times.
I'm not guys are many a time than spar in their competition.
That put it right there because you have your,
you have your,
your tempo exposed and you know when you get hit in the temple and knocked April
or Librium off,
you know,
you can't get,
your body's not responding like the mind is and he'll be right there in his,
like I still over over loop,
my punches are telegraphing.
I'm like,
it felt like someone stopping me or something like that.
Like it was crazy.
That's why I said that.
Ooh.
You know what I mean?
I kid you not,
I kid you not like some Gypsy man.
Come on with it.
I don't understand that.
I understand it now.
You know,
I understand everything,
but you to have to give some credit to him and he's,
he's a phenomenal boxer.
His style and his movement.
I mean,
and to see him pull that off and be that fresh even in the 12th me,
how to have that kind of endurance to get up after you knocked him down.
Yeah.
You definitely,
I definitely take nothing from him.
He was,
he was,
he was a great fighter that night.
You know,
he definitely brought his best and that's all you can.
That's all you can bring is your best and put on a performance.
That's why,
you know,
when we made this fight happen,
because it didn't take long for us to make this fight him.
He was just,
we both,
he reached out to me and said,
you know,
I feel embarrassed for what,
what Josh dealing doing to you and then,
you know,
and I want to fight it.
Let's make it happen.
Let's show the world who's the best,
who's the two best in the,
in the,
in the business,
like,
Bro,
let's make it happen.
You know,
it was just like that for a conversation.
I like the build up to the fight too because both of you were very confident and
Bolty we're talking,
you know,
you're going to beat the other and knock each other out.
But at the end of the fight,
when it was over,
it was nothing but respect.
It was nothing but respect.
And in,
in this day and age,
man,
it's just,
there's something nice to see about two dudes who just went to war for 12 rounds
and it turned out to be a draw.
And even after all of that,
nothing but respect,
right?
Most definitely.
And that's what it's all about.
You know,
two guys can be to be at each other and you know,
let's say we want to hurt each other even to the point and say,
you want to kill each other.
You know what I mean?
It's just the buildup is part of the sport,
you know?
Um,
it's to,
it's up to us to be as professional as possible when it comes to that because
we're not going to really punch is other than the wins.
What are,
why would we mess up on Monday when we were trying to support our children,
you know,
um,
a lot of things that happened in the,
in the,
in the press conferences and stuff was because of others.
Everybody else want to push and shove.
The ones that don't really matter,
they're not going to be in the ring.
Everybody want to push and shove.
So it makes it look worse than what it really is.
When you got two guys that really,
that matters that's getting in the ring,
you know,
but even,
a lot of people like,
oh they smiling at each other,
they're doing this.
Like that don't mean nothing.
We still got to get in the ring at the end of the day and punch each other in
the face.
And that's the big thing about it.
He wanted to put on a great performance and support his family as well as I,
you know,
especially cause it's been in my country,
I felt like I had the world attention.
Now I've been waiting for this moment for so long.
It's like I gotta make it gotta make a great stand and you know,
that wouldn't all the um,
the pressure and,
and,
and so anxious.
I,
this is,
I was anxious to do something that I already does and that's in fights in
devastating fashion.
I didn't have to force that.
And I know that if I force it never happens like I wanted,
you know what I mean?
But it was just,
it's just overwhelming to have the world attention,
you know?
How much would it have visit field then a regular fight.
It felt just,
it was amazing.
It was amazing man.
I swear it was just to come out there and just,
you know,
come out and just feel the energy of the people.
They were so excited and I was like,
I already knew who all was concerned peoples coming cause we was,
you know,
but it doesn't matter who was there.
It's just the point of just having the center of attention.
I didn't have to fight against no other sport and then like they,
cause you know his hard here in America,
it's hard to make it in the word America.
Every time I fought I've had to fight against other sports and certain things,
you know?
And it's always always been difficult.
Especially every fight I've had to promote it by myself cause these guys are
scared to talk or then some of them,
you know,
or teeth,
he spoke Spanish,
although it was an epic fight.
He spoke Spanish and sometime I had to do something to Spanish TV,
you know,
for my,
because they went through it like it was.
Yeah.
You know,
just to get it out,
you know.
But we're fury.
I knew I had the right dancing partner.
Well it seems for you that considering how recently you actually started boxing,
I mean,
what do you,
what do you 11 years in now?
How many of us?
That's fucking crazy.
You just still learning,
which is insane.
If you're getting,
you're getting better.
I mean as you're the champion,
you're
getting better.
That is a,
I mean a guy like Louis Ortiz is an epic dance partner for that cause you're
dealing with this guy who goes to the cube and amateur program.
He's a southpaw is a big motherfucker,
you know,
good boxer man.
Real
over 360 some elders or flights,
you know,
that's a lie.
If I had that meant that much experience,
you know,
you just never know and he's another one you knocked out late in the fight.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
I think he had the most difficult style.
Anyone on fault though thus far though?
Just being South Pole,
you don't really get too much training guys with Southport and not too many
around us heavyweight and,
and,
and he's a very slick and fast counter puncher.
That's what he waits on.
No,
with fighting him.
I really,
really,
really had to think about my next move.
We're going there,
what I had to do,
you know.
Um,
so our teeth,
I understand why a lot of these guys don't want to fight or to use.
They say he owed,
but they don't want to get in there.
They don't want to go against this old,
the old man though,
you know,
he's not tool now he's nine years old,
but he's not,
he moved his last fight.
Man,
he looked phenomenal.
You know what I mean?
He just,
he moves good.
He's,
his jab is outstanding and he's so well schooled.
You know,
it's like you see the little stutter faint that he does.
He Pops Out,
jab on it and he's always reading you looking for your reactions.
He's a beast.
Yes he is.
And I always give him credit for that until I see someone just come in and
dominate him.
We,
even with me and him,
we had,
uh,
a connection between our daughters,
you know,
cause he's got an year daughter as well.
And as well as I,
that's why I,
when a lot of stuff started coming out with him,
you know,
saying that he did drugs and not passing the test,
the um,
the bottle tests and stuff,
all that,
I still wanted to fight him.
I still wanted the blessing with the opportunity because of his daughter cause I
can relate to him just like,
just like I say this,
the store w were fear reselling with the uh,
mental illness and stuff.
Like how people was emotionally tired.
Like I got emotionally tied to our teas because he was a father that dealt with
a child with a disability as well as I,
so I know how hard it is to take care of children with disabilities.
And I know it takes a lot of money,
you know,
so I'm,
I'm always for him,
you know,
I've,
I've been talking about him every since that time we fought win,
lose or draw.
I would've still been talking about him because of the emotional ties that I had
with them.
I understand them.
And when you understand the person,
you root for that person,
no matter what,
no matter who's side you're on or whatever,
when a person has something,
you feel like it's worser than the next person.
Or you can relate,
you know,
you,
you want them to win.
You know,
it's beautiful man.
And I think that,
uh,
having a guy like Ortiz,
as,
uh,
an opponent that's one of those fights that think for a guy like you who doesn't
have a lot of amateur experience,
when you,
when you fight a guy that's that seasoned and you get to see you like what it
looks like,
you get to see what it looks like when you're in the ring with a guy who's had
just as he said,
300 plus amateur fights or overall,
that's a,
I mean,
that's an amazing learning opportunity,
right?
Stuff.
Then most affluent.
Then,
um,
you know,
I just just had the confident that I was,
I was the best.
I was,
no matter what he had always going with that confident though I blocked
everything that um,
his accomplishments in that we knew what we was up against,
you know,
but you know,
they was calling him the bogeyman or the division and at that point of time I
still needed to prove myself because you know,
people still doubting me.
They had been down to me from the start of my career.
I was like,
since nobody don't want to fight them,
I want to bless them with this opportunity.
So these next moves that I've made,
which the Vern to Dan or teeth,
the inferi well there's to Vern highlight knockouts,
one of the most ridiculous all time when you stand there with your hands down,
step forward and it's like,
it was a comic book scene.
It's like the way you knocked him out.
Like I said about like you being a bad guy in a movie.
It seemed like you were a bad guy in a boxing movie,
but it didn't make any sense.
You are the guy.
Like if I was,
say if there's someone who was a,
I was a coach of a good guy and I was sitting ringside and I was watching you do
that,
we'd be like,
Shit.
Oh,
okay.
I'm going to tell you,
man,
when I stood over him like that,
I was outside of my body.
I could see me and him standing there and like I was a third person.
I can't explain it,
you know?
And then when I started throwing the punches,
like I went back into my body and start wailing on him or whatever.
I can't,
I can't explain that feeling.
Yeah.
There's so many different things.
That one too,
because I got shared so much online.
Yeah.
That was the start of it.
Millions and millions of people saw that online and they're like,
what in the fuck is this guy got in his hand?
And that's when they started.
Who is this guy?
We haven't heard about this guy before him.
Yeah.
It's like everybody's waking up to the heavyweight division.
All of a sudden it was so true and it was the perfect convert.
There it is.
I,
that dude play it for the beginning,
Jamie.
Here it goes.
Come on.
You know,
straight boxing skills.
I,
I got boxing skills.
You know,
when,
when I first Fordham,
I showed all that I stayed disciplined.
I didn't abandon the game plan,
you know,
and I showed people that I could box.
Yeah.
And he told that was probably the only time I just really just stay super
disciplined.
Not despite,
but the first one and this one right here.
I went outside of my body right here.
I was standing,
then I came back.
I kid you not,
I don't know what the hell was going on with me.
That was ridiculous.
It was ridiculous.
No,
he did.
Yeah,
he was,
he was quite upset.
That's the strangest little concoction he's got on dreadlocks there.
Yeah,
look like tape.
that seems like that would get in the way,
but keep it up.
You know the Haitians believe in that too.
That was,
that was sweet too.
And then the referee get calmed.
Me Ref I don't,
is
that,
it wouldn't be funny of the web with the Lego.
He wrote to the other corner,
you talk about a movie that would have been,
but you know,
they're five Ryder was to real store or you know,
in of public perception.
Exactly.
I knew I was really good.
So with that,
especially when it went viral and then coming back with the Ortiz maybe cause
the people that were more interesting to see what I'm going to do now cause
people tune in now whether they they love me or hate me,
they tune in to see can I knock the next personnel,
you know,
at this point of time,
because a lot of people didn't even know I was an Olympian.
You know?
Um,
you know,
people I don't really even get recognized for really being the WBC champion,
and others,
people eyes,
he just,
that motherfucker
you out.
You know what I'm saying?
Everywhere I go now it's different.
Tyson fight,
they realize you're the champ.
I mean you used to be,
I mean obviously the,
the belts are fragmented because there's a lot of sanctioning organizations,
but it used to be there was Anthony Joshua in you.
But people are not paying attention to Anthony Joshua right now.
No,
it's just,
it's like he's literally had been forgotten.
Most definitely.
And that's a,
that's a great way to put it.
It's really been forgotten.
He's defended his title since the Klitschko fight.
How many times?
Twice.
Maybe three.
I'm not sure.
I remember the Parker was Parker.
Yeah,
Parker was after Parker.
Um,
was it,
the attacker was tackling before then?
Well,
what is interesting is if,
if this continues,
you know,
if you entice and have a rematch and then you eventually get to fight Anthony,
Joshua,
if you guys fight in Europe,
I mean you might be able to fill up some giant fucking crazy ass soccer arena.
Sometimes.
It's going to be crazy.
I mean if you,
if you go over to England and fight him there,
that would be insane because he's a giant superstar over there.
Most definitely.
I,
I definitely,
um,
would definitely be able to go over there.
You know,
you get an opportunity to go over there.
even if for any willful Joshua,
even if it was someone I want to expand out there as well too.
Uh,
but um,
we definitely get a fight with Joshua out there and then probably bring a
hundred hundred thousand or plus.
You know,
the only thing about the UK,
a lot of people,
a lot of people think that's where the money is,
but that's not true.
You know,
they got a cap on their money,
you know,
it ain't like,
it ain't like here in America.
America always be will be the Mecca of boxing.
Anything pertaining to that because the money is here,
you know,
how they sell their paper view and how we sell.
I was just like day and night.
They $20 a week go from shit,
the cheapest 50 sum on up to $100 and people pay for people.
You know,
it's fascinating and people think because you see more people equals more
dollars,
but you know,
and that's,
you know,
it's a cow is a cow per day.
You can only make so much over there.
And that's it.
If it was that,
if it wasn't that fact,
then you'll see more people from America going to the UK to fight.
Right.
You know,
casinos in Vegas or they're,
they're probably gonna want to do this fight next.
That's where they want it because they want all that extra gambling money in
restaurant money and show money.
Right.
That's where I would likely,
I would,
I would say it's likely gonna want
it could be,
you know,
we got a lot of places,
I wouldn't mind going back to New York as well.
Boxing's recording.
Yeah.
I mean,
you know,
you've got so many diverse people there,
um,
a lot of people look at travels and stuff like that,
you know,
all those be busy and stuff,
people won't still,
to be easy access.
He,
Vegas,
Vegas makes it easy for people because you know,
the airport is right there and then five minutes away you're on the Strip and
that's what most of the people be at and stuff.
But you know,
we'll,
we'll see when the time comes.
You know,
I'm open for any,
any,
any place,
you know,
when you guys talking about a rematch maybe,
uh,
we're looking at April,
May,
June,
somewhere up in there,
you know,
and uh,
we'll see what happens.
I'm excited though,
you know,
he said he back in the gym,
he text,
he hit me up,
he sent me a video saying how you back in the gym and stuff like that.
And I just hit back him likewise because it's crazy because his mindset is,
it's being back in the gym and mine's is the same way.
You know,
I been,
I been traveling a lot talking about this fight.
Like it's been like I'm already,
you know,
it in discussion with certain outlets or whatever.
It's like we've been boosting up this neck,
this rematch fight.
Like it's,
it's,
it's almost here.
It's been crazy though.
This is what my career needed as well too,
you know?
Um,
so I don't mind,
I've been from La to New York.
I'm just again from New York now I'm back here.
They're now offering to go to my original home time.
I got some things I got to do out there.
Enjoy the holidays.
I'm going to take a vacation with my family and then once I get back on back
into the gym myself.
Boxing fans,
hardcore boxy fans already knew who you are,
but this was the breakthrough fight for the general public.
This is a breakthrough fight where people know about it now and the next fight.
The rematch.
First of all,
you couldn't ask for a better dance partner when it comes to promotion.
I mean,
Tyson's fantastic on the microphone.
He's hilarious.
He's got that great accent.
It's fun to listen to him talk,
so you guys promoting this and getting ready for whatever it is,
April,
May,
June,
whenever it takes place.
I mean,
this is going to be probably one of the biggest heavyweight fights,
if not the biggest of all time.
Oh Man.
I'm just so excited.
You know what I mean?
Because I could see,
I can visualize it now.
I couldn't really visualize how big this could be come.
I knew it was going to be big,
but you just don't know how people are.
You know?
People are funny.
Especially,
you know,
people always have things to do.
You know,
you nailed it.
There was nothing,
nothing
else competing with you.
There's nothing else there to watch.
It was perfect.
It was a perfect storm and then it was in la,
so stars came out.
It was a big deal,
man.
It was amazing.
And I'll never forget it,
you know.
Excuse me.
Like I said,
I've been waiting for this.
I've been waiting for that moment for so long.
You know,
they don't have this problem in the UK because no matter,
you know,
no matter what they love boxing.
It's the second nature of sport.
They don't have college sports and professional sports that they had to deal
with boxes.
Like I said,
they're second nature of sport and you know,
Eh,
you know,
they don't have as many as people.
We have here the here like with maybe 66 million,
something like that.
Uh,
Alabama and Mississippi,
they can fit UK in Alabama and Mississippi combined to be other,
but they could fit the whole state and in Texas and still have space,
which over here we got so much.
We got how many colleges and professional sports and you know,
boxing is like probably the last sport,
you know,
on the list.
You know,
I probably,
you know,
exaggerating with that a little bit,
but it definitely seemed like that we definitely,
you know,
in the back and there's so much to compete with.
It's so,
it's so hard here to do it.
And then when you,
when you,
when you finally get that shine,
you know,
that's where it comes from.
You know,
when a minute and when you're in it and you understand it,
it's like how it's so hard.
It was to get it to get to this point,
you know,
down there 11 years and like to get to this point.
And then when you finally get his life here.
Yeah.
Big Time.
When you think back when you're driving that Budweiser truck,
I just,
ah,
I appreciate every job that I had.
You know,
I appreciate every,
everything that you know,
that it happened to me in my life.
It may allow me to appreciate,
you know,
who I am now allowed me to appreciate just the smaller things.
It allowed me to just be myself.
You know,
I'm a type of person that I don't really care about fame.
I don't even want to be called the celebrity.
You know what I mean?
I want to be able to live my life and do what I do.
I want to be able to enjoy just the smallest things in life.
I don't want people to take that away from me.
You know what I mean?
Being able to go to a movie or a grocery store or whatever and spend time with
the family you can't shut,
cause I like cooking.
I like going to the grocery stores,
the fresh market,
pick out my fruit and stuff that I want to put in my whatever I'm preparing for
the night and stuff like that.
I'm a people's person as well,
so I don't mind being bothered,
but you know,
it can't get crate.
I've seen other people get it get crazy for an iron man,
you know?
And they said it themselves like they don't,
they wished that they could do certain things,
normal things,
but people,
people,
people take it to the next level,
you know?
Get all in your bit,
especially after this fight,
like I of had to cut some people,
you know,
I didn't had to cut some people because they intentions was already wrong.
They seen a potential.
I put they,
they seen the opportunity and they tried to make moves on me,
you know,
already you know,
in different than,
that's why I said lonely at the top,
you know,
because you get to the point where you don't know who to trust.
You start down everybody around you.
You know,
I'm an energy person so I'm always re refreshing the feeling of the energy.
Let me see what it feels like.
You know what I'm saying?
Another,
I always allow me to meet certain people to be around certain people because if
you change your presence,
the energy just to just,
it will change as well too.
It changes.
It shifts the way you feel when you're around.
Then all of a sudden you feel like they're looking for angles and trying to
profit off of you.
They're trying to get you to do things.
Yes.
You know?
Eh,
you know,
I'm a,
I'm a strong minded person.
I got a lot of strong minded men around me.
I always tell people we speak positive.
We think positive and re surround.
I was helped by positive,
you know,
positive energy,
and then I will,
results is always positive.
The only time you ever see me,
you know,
acting out.
I would say if someone come and break that piece,
you'll never find me and my brothers,
you know out,
you know,
mess with someone's starting in anything.
I'm not a,
I'm not,
I'm not the one that started anything because I want peace.
I don't even want to see a fight outside.
If it's not in the boxing ring,
I'll walk away if I see it on the outside because I feel like they don't know
what they doing.
You know what I mean?
Is there something could happen easily.
You see guns being pulled out now a days and you know any little thing.
So I started to stay away from confrontation as much as possible.
That's why I thank God that I'm a homebody.
You know,
if I'm not here,
I'm at home,
you know,
back and forth because they say when you had to find,
when you had to,
you know,
find things to do when you had to leave home all the time,
you don't have a peaceful home.
And um,
I believe in that,
you know,
I don't understand when you're,
when it's busy,
you have to work and stuff.
That's one thing.
But you know,
when you just said,
man,
let's go here.
Let's get out and do it.
See,
I don't want to,
I don't,
I don't put myself out there to be a risk for no one.
You know,
my risk is at home.
If something's going to happen,
then you know,
the Auntie who was at home,
you know,
I don't,
I don't put myself out there to the half chance chances at the chances of where
people look down and it's like,
Hey,
let's do this.
Let's do that to him.
Or I tried to,
because I know what I'm capable of doing.
You know what I mean?
And I like being me.
I just like being laid back down to Earth,
get along with everyone.
I'm a people's person and a lot of people will never know it because they only
see the perspective of me and the ring.
Or they see me on youtube and those interviews,
yes.
You're a very mellow guy.
Like right now
I'm just,
I'm the coolest.
I'm the best,
you know,
and what's got to help to the train a lot.
So,
you know,
yeah.
It,
the stress
training constantly,
right?
Yeah.
I mean,
I get my times in,
you know,
if I'm not with my family,
I love my family.
You know,
I love,
I got some beautiful churches and I got a beautiful woman and I just,
I love being around them.
I love being able to see my children grow,
being able to see them smile,
you know,
tell me good morning or kiss me just own freewill without me having to tell
them.
We'll ask them.
They just come up and kiss me and say how much they love me and stuff.
It feels good.
The only way you want it.
If you want to see me cry,
deal with kids.
They don't even have to be my kids.
It can be others as well.
I love kids.
It's nothing.
And what hurts me so bad with kids is that to see some kids have to have to grow
fast,
faster than what they,
they normally would have to,
you know,
have to be a adult fast.
Because I,
I think your childhood years are some of your best years of your life because
you don't have really no responsibilities.
And when you get out into the real world,
that's when reality hits.
That's when it was like,
oh,
this,
this is real.
You know?
So my heart goes out to a lot of kids.
I love,
I love children.
And that what keeps me strong in this sport,
you know?
Do you worry about getting more famous?
Do you worry about the consequences?
I don't think about,
I don't think about getting more famous,
you know,
I,
I know it comes,
it comes with the territory,
you know,
and I,
and even if people know everything,
I just want people just,
you know,
don't,
don't hold me,
don't look at me as someone that,
that holds me higher than then you know,
people who have high,
high expectations for you.
And when you do something,
they think,
you know,
the biggest thing in the world that happened,
you can do the same thing is as a being that weren't getting met.
Donna does.
But because I have the name and he doesn't,
then it makes it even more,
you know,
worse than what he done.
You know,
I'm like,
we are humans.
We are gonna make mistakes.
We're going to do things.
They probably do some things that you don't supposed to do.
You get in trouble with doing.
You know what I mean?
It's just part of life,
you know?
And I never,
I never make myself seem like I'm better than anyone,
you know,
I'm a type of God.
I've talked to a homeless man and if the,
if the conversation led,
we until we a go,
I'm a people's person.
My mother was a people person.
The term is she never met strangers.
I never meet strangers because you can never know,
um,
by me and the active with a person.
Do I know that person or not?
Because of the how we are interacting with each other and that's just me.
I'm a people's person.
Cause you just never know who you may meet and what they can give you.
What advice or what you can kill them,
you know,
to make their day better,
or hug us say,
man I love you man.
You know,
that's,
that's the final things.
Like that's what life of Bach all about.
It ain't all so much about who you are and how much money you got because that
can be gone tomorrow.
You know,
it ain't about that,
you know,
it's about treating people with respect.
You treat me with respect.
I treat you no matter what,
what you are in life because you are human being.
And that's what I'm all about.
As you get more famous though,
you're going to get more.
The numbers are just,
that's where it gets unmanageable.
People start waiting for it.
Like you,
you ever see what it looks like when Manny Pacquiao is training?
No,
when he was in his,
especially when he's
trained in the Philippines,
is it was insane.
Like Freddie Roach was there with them and you know,
they'd be look outside and people be holding their phones up,
just waiting for him to look outside the window.
Just hundreds of people everywhere he goes.
And you know,
he lives in the Philippines,
so it's a,
he's the superstar and this incredibly poor country.
And he's a really humble guy too.
But it almost seemed,
I mean,
he handles it in an amazing way.
I don't know how that guy does it,
but he's,
he's very chill too.
Yeah.
Well he had to have,
you know,
he'd had been knocked down.
I had to be good and to be brought back up.
Light life teaches you lessons and,
and um,
and God bless you sometime with second chances,
you know,
and when you do get the second chance and you know how to handle a little bit
better than the first time,
you know,
hopefully you don't never have to go through nothing,
um,
dramatic,
you know,
or nothing severe,
to,
to learn a lesson,
you know,
because he definitely,
he probably would tell you itself,
you know,
there's a lot of things that he was doing that he had the correct,
I had to get herself right or whatever because it can take you away.
You know,
if a person dwell,
somebody,
not saying Manny did this,
but just talking in general,
if a person dwell so much on,
you know,
being famous and people loving them and knowing them and stuff like that,
like it can take that minor way from there and they'll become this type of
person.
That's when people say,
Oh,
you've changed,
you've changed.
You know,
and then they'll make,
I've seen it firsthand,
I've seen a person with no money and then when they get some money,
they don't know.
They changing,
you know,
it's just something that's happening and people would say you changing.
And I'd be like,
no,
I'm just,
they,
I think they're just them.
And you know what I'm saying,
but not in reality,
you know,
uh,
slowly but surely they're changing and stuff like,
and I,
I'm a,
I'm a type of person that I'm not judging mental people alive.
I'm a type of person that whatever you're doing your life,
you chose to do that.
I mean,
who am I to judge you?
I don't judge people because I don't want them to judge me.
You know what I mean?
Whatever.
I'm the type of person that whatever you get involved with,
it's a consequences.
That is consequences behind your ashes that you,
you're going to have to face whether you do the right thing or the wrong thing,
you're going to have to face the consequences behind it.
And only you going to have to face it,
you know,
at the end of the day.
And that's why I respect people.
I,
you know,
whatever you do,
you know that show,
it's your life.
Have Fun with your life.
You know,
we make mistakes to correct them.
Loan we learned from my mistakes,
then,
hey,
we're all human,
you know,
now coming this rematch,
what would you do differently then?
This rematch,
what I would do differently.
I would,
I wouldn't abandon the body.
I heard him twice in the body.
I should have kept going with the body mark.
What kept telling me to keep going to the body,
going to the head,
go to the hair,
go,
go to the body.
And I've been in that whole thing.
Um,
I would probably be jam more and I'd definitely be more calmer this time around.
You know,
when you,
you know,
though,
when you,
when you find the god twice you the first time you get to experience him,
the second time y'all kind of know each other a little bit better than the first
time.
And um,
I really feel fear.
We brought his fear about the best of theory,
but it definitely wasn't the best of Deontay wilder.
And,
uh,
at this point of how we know what to train for because I don't think he's going
to change nothing up.
He fought a great game,
you know,
a great fight.
And I don't think isn't,
you know,
nothing that could be changed up.
Maybe he'd probably lose.
If you get into GM now,
he'll,
he'll be a little bit lighter for sure.
And that could be me.
That could mean a little bit light on the feet though,
you know what I'm saying?
Uh,
but we definitely gonna adjust,
make some small adjustments and I can't wait.
It's going to,
it's going to be explosive.
Now when you do a training camp for a big fight like this,
how many weeks do you prepare for this?
Five was three months.
Three months.
And so do you start up and start slowly ramping and who,
who sets your schedule in terms of like what you do every day?
Um,
with camp,
my,
my time train and Jay,
he sets up like all the sparring partners and stuff.
I got strength and conditioning coach and,
and different and in shelves and stuff like that.
So we,
I got all that under,
uh,
um,
I got all that,
you know,
or someone else.
Here's all your foods or prepared to die.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
For sure.
That's why I was surprised I came in so such a low,
even at two 12
because you know in cabinet stuff
I got to such a high metabolism.
It just,
I just never know.
I don't,
I don't really just keep up with my weight.
I'm not in type of guy that I weigh in all the time or whatever.
I think because I've got an item gotten by with this power for so long,
it's like,
you know,
it just,
it's just an image,
you know,
I can't gain weight.
Like I,
I don't understand.
You know,
I may have to do that blood testing thing and see like they got to where you can
take your blood and they can do a test and see what types of food would make you
gain weight.
And I think I'm,
I'm,
I'm a try that out.
But you want to get anyway.
Yeah.
Well,
I want to get a little bit,
I always had the goal being to 45 with my six,
seven,
six,
600 frame.
But being two 45 you might get tired or in the later rounds you say you gained,
you gained weight and keep the speed.
So you know,
as you gaining,
you continue to,
to work,
keep your speed.
That's how we,
that's how we always wanted to,
to uh,
to go edit because we had a lot of guys that,
you know,
that specialize in bulking and stuff like that.
And we didn't want that.
We didn't want,
I didn't want to bulk up,
you know what I mean?
I wanted to gain weight and keep the speed,
you know,
but just as much as I gained weight,
it much as I work out in my tablet lives,
I'm so high.
So it's like,
it's like I lose weight and my sleep.
How many times a day?
We was eating about three,
three times.
Three to four times a day.
And like what kind of foods?
Special?
Yeah,
we was eating steak,
fish and chicken.
You know,
a lot of,
lot of,
uh,
low carb.
He okay.
You know,
um,
we were eating,
you know,
I definitely have us with some in the south,
I had to have me some Greens and cornbread,
you know.
Um,
we was doing a lot of,
um,
let me see.
Damn.
Getting rid of my,
I know we had mashed potatoes,
we had a lot of a hop and Johns.
How John is like,
um,
like a pinto beans and rice together with onions and stuff like that.
You'll put up squash,
do a lot of spinach,
spinach.
I was doing a lot of tuna.
Um,
so just whole foods.
Yeah,
most definitely beverage,
very happy food.
You know,
I get all my stuff from the whole food vitamins or anything like that.
Correct.
I was using the vitamins and stuff.
I was using the vitamins.
I did the vitamins,
I did the whole nine with the vitamin things like I really had to,
they would bring me,
uh,
I,
um,
a kind of holder for the pills and stuff for each day of the week and stuff like
that.
And just and still like I wouldn't gain with the RTS for,
I didn't gain like still like I'm like what the world going on with my body.
I don't know what type of freakish body I have.
You know,
because I tried to put on the weight,
we're going to try another method this time I'm going to actually try to eat,
try to eat every three hours or so like that.
I'm going to have my assistant with me and whatever.
So he'll bring me protein shakes and you know,
and being able to,
I just eating something,
I want to put it,
I want to see what this weight thing a little like,
you know,
um,
we're going to,
like I said,
this next fight is going to be good,
but the problem is you're doing so well.
I don't know if I would do shit different.
No,
fix it if it's not broken.
In terms of that,
I know you're eating,
the thing about you is your endurance is so consistent.
When you're in the 12th round,
your endurance is very consistent.
It's not like a lot of big guys.
They drop off later in the fight and you see them leaning on each other more,
taking more time in between exchanges,
you know,
trying to pace themselves out,
trying to restore that energy.
You've got that energy in the 12th round and part of that might be because
you're walking around to 12 to 15 and you fighting two oh nine,
it might,
that might be up a real big positive because obviously the power is not an
issue.
So why else would you want any weight?
You know,
uh,
like I was telling him about,
you know,
some of my team want to see it.
They want to see cer certain adjustments or whatever and they know,
they know that I'm only going to do what I want to do,
you know,
they know they can't make me a forced me to do then.
But I am a team player though.
You know what I'm saying?
I am a type of person that if everybody in agreeance on something,
no matter how I feel about it,
I'm like,
all right,
because we are a team.
We always been this way.
Like with my team,
I got,
I got a great team,
you know,
we never leave a discussion with dollar.
We just never do.
You know,
no matter what it is,
we always come to a green some something.
And with this situation I told them,
I like,
all right,
I'm gonna try to,
what do they want?
How much they want you to gain.
They haven't said how much they want you to put some way,
put some weight on.
And I told him,
your strength and conditioning coach is this your boss management and stuff like
that.
Yeah.
Everybody in the grants.
So you know,
I could use to say,
Nah,
I ain't doing this and my power,
you know,
which I've said before,
I like,
well I really don't need to wait.
It's just like what you were just describing.
I like,
I was saying the same thing.
I mean my,
I got power and I got true power and,
um,
but I just started thinking,
I'm like,
I'm a team player as well,
you know,
I'm never feel like,
although I'm the fighter that's going to be in the ring,
they not going to be fighting.
But we were a team.
I'm a team sport.
So how much,
I mean I'm a team player and you know,
they have you doing weightlifting.
Yeah.
We're going to do the weight lifting.
What are you doing it for this camp?
Most definitely.
What kinds of stuff?
We live for strength,
so we do a lot of stuff lifting for strips,
cleans,
that kind of stuff all at the ropes,
you know,
um,
pull ups,
different things like that.
But,
um,
I'm going to go back to,
uh,
not only lifting for strength but for balance as well too.
You know,
we used to do a lot of things with the balance ball and different ways with the
balance ball.
There's a lot of stuff with the man's ball.
Um,
I used to have this training that I loved.
You know,
he was amazing what happened to him
when I had my title fight.
You know,
I think he started listening to people,
you know,
think he should,
he saw the potential he taught.
He saw,
he saw,
he saw opportunity where he,
he felt like he can make a lot of money off of me,
you know,
and it wasn't the case.
It's like we wouldn't short cutting him.
We was,
he was getting paid the right amount of money.
But you know how people don't understand boxing,
they think it's more intuitive or you can get more.
He tried to get rich off of me,
really,
you know,
off of one client.
I'm like,
Bro,
it's many of it meant ease of use.
You know what I'm saying?
It's very fused.
I mean,
you know what I'm saying?
And it's like we won.
I'm like,
I miss him.
And,
but when you,
when you,
when you look at me like a piece of meat and try to benefit more than what it
really tried to do,
then you know,
you didn't,
you didn't cross me.
Like you can't be trusted at that point.
But he had me write,
he used to have me write,
I loved everything he used to do.
We still talk about him to this day and we had to move on though,
you know,
because we know what his intentions were.
And just imagine now you let them back in.
You know,
they may do right then they may not,
you know,
you just never know.
But that is a problem.
Once you have conflict,
once you started having conflict and you continue to have conflict escalates and
then people always do think that they're worth more.
Now is it,
say it though,
because I'll toggle my,
he used to have me write everything.
Oh Man.
This is a thing that I think that there's a lot of good trainers out there.
All you have to do is you kind of explain what the guy was doing and how he was
setting it up.
And you'll find a guy,
especially when you consider all the d mean it's not just for boxing,
but there's so many guys that do that for pro sports and now they're adapting to
boxing and MMA scene.
A lot of this as well.
You're seeing all these guys who are organizing these programs that,
you know,
they might've been doing NFL or NBA now instead they're doing it for boxing for
Ellie Mae.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a lot of things that,
um,
in strength training that,
that we do is a lot of things that we didn't do because,
you know,
I'm getting away with a lot of things.
There's a lot of things in training that I,
that we does that a lot of fighter just don't do.
Like,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like the,
you know,
most of them when I go in,
I'm hitting,
you know,
when I have account is mostly just a,
I'm hitting the speed,
uh,
hitting the Mitts,
you know,
hitting the mitts and going over different things.
I barely go in and hit speed bad.
I definitely don't do no jump roads,
you know,
sometime hit the heavy bags,
you know what I'm saying?
Because of the,
the power that I have is certain thing we trying to get coordination down and
timing.
You know what I mean?
Because I know if I hit any man,
they're going to sleep.
You know what I mean?
We know this and I'm,
this is just a lot of things that,
that I just,
I didn't do because I'm getting away with it and I'm still,
I still get away with it,
you know what I mean?
But at this point in time in my career,
now we have the world attention.
You know,
I want a better me,
I want a new me.
It's a new Deontae coming,
you know,
and uh,
I'm so serious about it.
That's why when my team talk about certain things,
I'm like,
I'm down for it.
Let's make it happen.
Let's see what happens.
We can at least try you.
That's how I can get him the benefit of doubt.
Although I may feel a certain way because I'm still,
I'm the one in there fighting.
But like again,
like they did,
we were a team so I at least can get him the benefit of the doubt and,
and put forth an effort and to try.
And
when you're going through a camp,
uh,
how many days a week are you doing strength conditioning and are you running in
the mornings?
Like how,
how are you scheduling your workouts?
Um,
stress right.
Is,
is,
is three times a week,
you know,
we go light on sparring days because,
I got all these big guys in there and stuff,
so it needs some strength for sparring.
Um,
but we were going three times a Monday,
Wednesdays and Fridays.
So on sparring days you go light or you go light on sparring,
sparring days we go light with the weights,
life,
stuff like that.
You have energy for sparring?
Correct.
Right.
And then on days where you're not sparring,
then you hit it hard.
Correct.
So,
um,
so somebody organizes all this stuff for you now when you do strength and
conditioning,
are you running as well?
Well,
swimming to did we,
we don't,
we don't like jogging.
I don't do my jog and you know,
we do everything fast.
We want to,
to,
to act.
We want to activate the fast twitch muscles.
You know what I'm saying?
We do everything with rapid speed.
If I'm,
if I'm doing anything consist of me moving,
my feet is spreading and stuff,
stuff like that.
And I worry a 45 pound vest on me as well too.
And all my exercise and everything that I do,
they have that extra weight on chin,
ups,
school,
everything,
everything.
I used to do that with this training I was talking about,
you know,
we used to do everything with this.
Do you do plyometrics like that as well?
Not so much.
I still do every now and again,
every now and again,
but we're going to do a lot of things.
We've,
we've,
we've been,
uh,
we fin to enhance it.
Or like I said,
I'm here.
I feel like I'm here and I know just being regular me just doing things that I
would normally would do,
gotten me to this point.
But now I just feel like I'm on a whole nother level now.
I just feel like,
like now it's time to apply the things that need to be really done and not the
things that you know,
you can do and get away with.
You know what I'm saying?
And that's just how I feel at this point in time.
So come to rematch.
They will see a new Deontay wilder.
Well,
that is one of the things that's exciting about it.
You're,
like I said,
is that if you're an only been boxing for 11 years,
when you're just starting that really touch your potential,
you're still putting combinations together,
you're still putting your foot work with those combinations and learning the
moves.
I mean,
you're not talking about a guy like Louise or teas who's gone through it,
just this gigantic amateur career and professional career.
And he knows what he knows.
He's not learning.
He's maintaining your learning.
Yeah,
most definitely.
It's one of the things that's so exciting about you in this stage of your career
being an emerging as a star.
Yeah,
most definitely.
You know,
just to,
just to learn.
I always said that when a,
when a,
when a witness,
nothing else to learn,
then I don't want to be in this sport.
I don't want to be a know it all.
Do you have an exit strategy?
Do you know when you want to get out?
Um,
my goal is to unify the division,
whether it'd be one chapter,
one face,
one name,
it'd be the undisputed,
the undefeated,
the unified heavyweight champion of the world.
I want to defend that for a couple of years.
Maybe until I be all the top guys in the division,
even maybe in the,
in the second tier.
And then once I complete that,
I'm like,
I'm done to,
maybe I got more years.
I say,
I say I have 10 or less,
but I'm more on the tenure.
I'm on the less,
lesser of the years to anything.
I just want to accomplish my [inaudible] old man.
And,
uh,
you are,
you're 30 now,
(313) 033-0330 three started at 21.
You know,
though too,
I don't take too much punishment,
you know what I mean?
Um,
that's it.
I always tell,
you know,
I got a great team outside of boxing.
You know,
one day I will get that phone call and they will say,
Mr. Wilder,
you don't have to work no more than your life.
You know,
I built for,
for four generation wealth.
This is not just for the moment in time or you know,
just right now what I can do,
it's all for my children and will always be for my children.
A lot of people can come in with different stories about themselves during this,
this and this.
But when they're dealing with your children,
you know,
you always want to see them outgrow you.
Right.
You know?
So with that being said,
they got a long life to live and it's up to me to be able to provide for them so
they can be able to,
to do what they,
they need to do.
I want to,
I want them to be able to,
to do what they need to do,
but,
but definitely not.
Do not just sit on the ass where they don't want to have to do Nafta.
I ain't into that business.
I,
man,
it's always been hard for me.
You know what I mean?
No opportunities that haven't really been given and if it hasn't been the
opportunity to given it's a smaller,
what I had to create opportunity inside of opportunity is always been like that
for my life.
But don't you think that's also part of the reason why you have so much power
behind you and not just physical power,
punching power,
but determinations?
Yes.
Because you've had to overcome adversity.
You've had to push through and that,
that gives you that willpower and most of,
and then you hit it,
you hit the nail right on the head.
Now,
are you a boxing fan outside of your own career?
Do you enjoy boxing?
I do.
I try to attend as many as twice as I can,
you know,
um,
I have,
uh,
you know,
I definitely have a lot of stuff that goes on and tried to get me out there even
more.
Um,
so,
you know,
we definitely be working on the outside of boxes,
but I'm definitely,
yeah,
I definitely enjoyed the sport.
Just see all other guys.
Do you,
um,
when you think about yourself as being this heavyweight who is a,
you know,
at the top of the division now,
and you look at all these younger,
uh,
lighter weight fighters,
you know,
like guys like Terrence Crawford,
Mama Chanko,
all these really fantastic up and coming fighters.
Do you,
uh,
do you try to apply any of this stuff that they do?
No,
not necessarily.
You know,
um,
it's good to look at it and stuff like that,
but I'm just me,
I like my style.
Um,
and you know,
uh,
I never,
I never looked to see what those,
what those God does and tried to apply to,
to my style.
No,
no.
Parents have ways either,
you know,
my ultimate all time.
Um,
well,
my idol is Muhammad Ali,
you know,
a love Mohamani and not only just what he did in the inside of the ring,
cause he's lost many a times.
He,
you know,
he could predict certain things,
but then sometimes he petitioned don't come true.
It was basically what he did on the outside.
He was,
he knew who you were.
He knew what he represented,
he knew where he stood for.
And you know,
and that was strong for me because I'm the same way,
you know,
to this day I know who I am.
I know what I represent,
I know what I stand for,
you know,
and,
uh,
that meant a lot to me just to see him just specially in those times and days to
be so strong and just paved the way,
you know,
just like Jack Johnson paid the way from home line of eating,
and in Mohammad,
Ali paid away for us and so forth and so on with all the other great fighters.
Um,
but you know,
we have tried to add certain moves,
you know,
uh,
Evander Holyfield used to do this year step,
step back,
like a counter punch.
He had tried to come in on you and then when he gets you to react,
he has stepped back and tried to come and punch.
We got certain codes that we will,
it's just like baseball or whatever.
We got certain things that we can say,
you know,
um,
and then I'll know what they saying just so it won't be like,
it's just regular boxing.
Do the one,
two,
or staying like this because they understand what you're saying.
But if you lose it in terms like give it nicknames or whatever,
uh,
we tried to do that or whatever,
but how bad,
how beneficial would it be for you to work with different people?
I don't know.
I don't,
um,
I love my team,
you know what I mean?
Say Ever.
Not have your team,
right.
I mean,
but I feel like a guy like you,
you have so much talent.
It would be fascinating to see you just,
you know,
take a day with Virgil Hill,
take your day with this guy.
Would you get together with different people to see,
it just seems like you have so much possibility.
There's so much.
My only thing is my own thing with it is that will,
would they egos,
you know,
be able to handle mines,
you know a lot of these trainings.
How Big Egos,
not saying that the the,
you know,
not saying that the guys you name have,
I'm just saying in general,
you know,
I never worked with none of them but you know when the egos coming together,
when the train to feel like they,
you need him,
you know what I'm saying and stuff like that then that's when things go wrong.
You know what I'm saying?
Cause some trying to do you need me,
you know,
they feel like if you don't have them then you know you're not going to be
successful.
You know,
cause I didn't have guys coming,
you know,
and with,
because I'm very dominant,
you know,
if if I don't see it that way,
you know what I'm saying?
Not saying that,
not saying that I would not do it,
but I would put my input into,
I'm not a type of person that just,
if I see it some way you see it a certain way.
If I see it some way then you know I'm not gonna Express,
Eh,
I'm not that type of part that just going to be quiet and just go along.
I'm going to suppress my opinion.
I'm going to tell you like,
Nah,
this is how I see it as well too.
That's why my team is so great.
Like they can see it and I could see a whole nother way,
but we put it in together.
We kind of make it mix where it can work.
Like all right,
I'm trying this and I see it.
I could see,
I could see one thing as well too in the ring,
you know?
And then we just make it work together.
The things is that you don't have any conflict in your team.
You know how giant that is.
Like,
Hey,
Jake is a fucking distraction.
When you see fighters that aren't getting along with their coaches or I can
along with their strength and conditioning trainer or whoever the fuck it is,
man.
As soon as you have issues with management,
you hate your manager.
I want to get out of my contracts.
That fucks up so many fighters,
careers it puts on the sideline for a long time.
Andre Ward,
I know so many of them on the sideline for awhile.
Brother Malique,
Scott,
you know there's a cro closest one of my does.
He was a great fighter but because of management and stuff like that,
he wasted so
many years.
Yeah,
it's very common.
It's very common.
So that's the beautiful thing about your arrangement.
You seem to have everything in order.
Right?
Most definitely.
You know,
I've got a great team man.
uh,
Mark Jay,
you know,
no got,
because you know,
I've got to,
I've got a great team of guys and um,
they,
they understand,
you know,
Jay never been in situation like this,
my long time trainer and I'm the first to come out of Alabama to do certain
things that I've done.
So we both have learned on the way,
you know,
especially being in the spotlight where you got more breathing,
two times welterweight champion,
84 Olympic gold medalists talks off.
It's amazing how I can hear him though.
Yeah.
Well it's amazing too that you got mark because mark when he was a welter weight
was a phenomenal knockout artist and similar to you and that he was long and
tall and Mark's always been like a very like even keeled intelligent guy,
you know.
So it's really interesting to see him make that transition to a trainer and with
you.
I think that's like a perfect fit.
Yeah,
most definitely.
Most w w when you can understand him,
you know,
he talks so soft,
but you know,
I'd been with him for a very long time so I could like,
I could,
you can be a thousand people in the,
in the audience.
I can,
I can.
Oh,
I remember back in the day,
man,
when,
when mark was in the Olympics,
man,
I remember watching him fight on ABC wide world of sports.
I remember when he fought Marlin's starling.
I remember those days.
You know,
he's a great guy.
the one thing about it is just everybody got positive energy,
you know,
that's big for me.
It was just like you said,
like when you get management and stuff you hate,
you hate them or you know,
don't want to work with them,
you know,
it'd be it,
it brings a voice or some type of avoidance in the,
in the group.
Like when you,
you know,
want to do something,
you don't love you like you love going to train.
But because of this certain person,
you don't want to be there,
you know,
it just knock your energy level down.
Like I said,
I've never dealt with it,
but I've had friends that have dealt with it before.
I've had my brother,
he'd dealt with it before,
you know,
and I,
so I,
I've seen you know,
firsthand.
You don't have to go to court and
can't do nothing.
You are on the shelf because of this and like,
uh,
over and over and over again.
Parts the crazy,
oh my goodness.
Lawsuits.
Yes.
Trying to figure out how you get out of your promotional content outlines a lot
of guys.
Yeah.
There's a lot of distractions.
Make you not want to train because you'll feel like your career's not going
nowhere.
Well,
there's somebody that needs guys because that becomes their primary focus
instead of just getting better and preparing for the next challenge and always
thinking about this legal issue you're going through.
Exactly.
Yeah.
No,
no.
You're fortunate in that regard.
You know,
most definitely,
no matter what people you look up on the mass,
because a lot of people like,
well you need another trainer's it.
But the thing about it,
you got to look at it and we didn't made it thus far.
Now,
what other,
what other guys in this sport is knocking every guy out,
you know?
Yeah,
definitely making them hit the hit the canvas like me,
you know,
40 and over 39 k.
Oh,
that's just not,
I know,
I know I got power,
but it still,
it still takes more than that.
You know what I mean?
Just you still gotta be able to throw the JAB and set it up to throw the right
hand and throw the hook behind that and stuff like that.
I got great trainers,
especially in mark,
you know,
he's a great trainer.
He teaches me as ways to throw the jab in different ways,
you know?
Although when I get in there and I,
I,
I look at it and I take my own judgment,
but I also listened to him as well too.
And at this point in time,
you know,
it's gonna be,
it's gonna be a lot more listening.
Like I see certain things because one thing I never want to do is if I hear you,
I see what you're saying,
but it's not right there at that moment in time.
And then I started taking what you see and then I wouldn't been getting hit in
the head or get knocked out.
Now I just never want to say,
well,
I'll listen to you when you,
you got me put on the ground,
but still listening to myself and getting,
putting on the ground,
you know what I mean?
Um,
but you know,
I love my guys.
I love my guys and um,
I can't wait for this.
I can't wait for the,
for the get back into the gym.
It's going to be a new,
a new me.
I can't wait to watch the rematch,
man.
It was a phenomenal and,
uh,
I really appreciate you coming in here.
I'm a big fan.
I was a big fan before that fight and I think the world's a big fan now.
So,
uh,
best of luck to you,
sir.
Blessing.
Thank you so much.
These Deontay wilder,
ladies and gentlemen,
the broad bomber.